[Música]
[Aplausos]
todos nós temos sonhos eu posso apostar
que cada um de vocês já realizou pelo
menos um deles o que aconteceu com todos
os outros
a palavrinha mais querem ver comigo tem
o sonho de abrir minha própria empresa
mais falta tempo e coragem
eu tenho um sonho de encontrar um
companheiro ou a companheira mas faltam
pessoas interessantes disponíveis
eu tenho um sonho de magra e c para
correr uma prova de rua mas falta tempo
para ir à academia
eu poderia continuar minutos e minutos
colhendo o depoimento de cada um de
vocês quando a gente deixa de lado a
palavrinha mais e assumir
responsabilidade sobre os nossos sonhos
sobre o nosso querer sobre a nossa
vontade é uma espécie de mágica acontece
e todo o nosso ser toda a nossa vontade
todas as nossas células
elas nos impulsionam em direção ao nosso
objetivo ao nosso sonho
isso aconteceu comigo quando eu deixei
de lado as desculpas quando eu deixei de
culpa o mercado o trabalho os
relacionamentos as circunstâncias de
vida
busquei a força necessária para ir atrás
do meu sonho que era um dia escalar o
everest a maior montanha do mundo
o sonho de infância do everest virou um
projeto de adulto que era preciso juntar
seis elementos principais
obviamente preparo físico escalada em
rocha e escala em gelo ganhar volume de
montanhas de altas montanhas montanhas
acima de 4 mil metros
viajar para algumas delas e viver essa
experiência tempo e dinheiro entre 2015
e
16 eu consegui orquestrar mais ou menos
esses seis elementos
eu aprendi a escalada em rocha num clube
aqui no rio de janeiro clube centro
excursionista do rio de janeiro
ali na avenida rio branco eu treinava
mais ou menos 88 dias na semana para
conseguir o preparo físico é necessário
4 v8 de oito vezes na semana duas vezes
por dia
eu viajei para a bolívia para aprender a
escala no gelo há um custo benefício
mais acessível do que me aventurar pra
ásia
por outro lado do mundo sendo que só a
passagem aérea já que estaria mais do
que essa essa expedição além disso eu
comecei a estruturar um plano para
ganhar volume de montanhas em cada um
dos continentes como embasamento um
preparo para o próprio everest
eu me lancei o desafio também de
concluir o projeto sete cumes que é
escalar a montanha de cada continente a
isso eu escalando o alasca a isso eu
quase chegando no cume do alasca
aí sou eu no continente antártico
tentando umas isso vinson que a montanha
daquele continente
é isso ou eu escalando a pirâmide
kastens a maior montanha da indonésia
para quem acha que na indonésia só tem
altas ondas têm altas montanhas também
entre 2015 e 2017 e 16
foi isso que eu fiz e no dia 19 de maio
de 2016
ao meio dia e um eu atingir o cume do
everest
numa escalada assustadora eletrizante
mais ou menos um mês depois de cumprir o
meu sonho de infância e também cumprir o
chamado projeto sete cumes que é
alcançar uma montanha de cada um dos
continentes como eu falei batendo o
recorde brasileiro de cumprimento desse
o montanhismo atual em um ano e nove
dias depois disso sucessivas entrevistas
dadas ainda por conta do feito do
everest me forçando a compartilhar
aprendizados tempo é necessário e
cheguei até a verbalizar algumas lições
daquela época nada grandioso se alcança
sozinho por exemplo para chegar em algum
lugar é preciso ter clareza de onde se
quer chegar
outro exemplo são os mais fortes do que
a gente imagina um outro exemplo baita
aprendizados não acham
não eram os mais importantes hoje eu
vejo que não eu até construir uma
equação do aprendizado
naquela época quando a gente vive uma
experiência a gente não aprende
a gente sente a experiência para que o
aprendizado aconteça é necessário tempo
e é necessário o efetivo compartilhar
com as pessoas a cada compartilhar eu
intensifico a experiência vivida e aí
sim eu aprendo extrai os melhores e mais
importantes lições o meu aprender a
aprender não tinha parado por aí
um mês depois de concluir o projecto das
montanhas eu engravidei
aos 38 anos começava ali uma outra
escalada que envolve a morar junto
formar um casal mudar de cidade
formar uma família tudo junto e
misturado e não necessariamente nessa
ordem
eu me perguntei eu e aí eu me peguei
pensando
será mesmo que ser protagonista da nossa
vida é a coisa mais importante
depois de longas noites amamentando e
ainda dando muitas entrevistas por conta
do feito do everest e do projeto sete
cumes
eu me dei conta de algo arrebatador
ah
desculpe eu me dei conta de algo
arrebatador como desaprender a ser
protagonista e colocar a vontade de
outras pessoas na frente da sua vontade
a necessidade de outras pessoas
à frente da sua necessidade a dor das
outras pessoas acima da sua dor
ora até então o que eu tinha aprendido
na vida era ser protagonista planejar
sente vontade de planejar executar e
sentir vontade planejar e executar
quando você tem um filho e um
relacionamento acontece tudo -
planejamento e execução acontece
frustração negociação deslizes
imprevistos e algumas execuções e nada
de planejamento
um recente estudo de raiva ainda em
andamento publicou que é um recente
estudo de harvard em andamento com os
senhores hoje senhores mas que
acompanhou 800 adultos entre 5 e 80 anos
de idade e publicou uma coisa incrível
que é sobre felicidade é feliz quem
mantém relacionamentos saudáveis e
duradouros
eu pergunto a vocês
será que para manter relacionamentos
saudáveis e duradouros
é preciso abandonar o protagonismo da
própria vida e para ser feliz
será que significa ausência de
protagonismo
eu deixo essa pergunta pra vocês
responderem
no meu caso aprendendo a vida inteira
ser protagonista eu aprendi sendo
protagonista vida inteira eu aprendi que
sim a ausência de protagonismo é
sinônimo de felicidade
e do contato mais profundo com aquilo
que a gente tem de mais humano que é
generosidade doação e amor e essas são
as lições que o tempo me permitiu e são
as verdadeiras lições que eu aprendi com
as montanhas
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]